j'étais chez une amie en jaser dans le
cadrage parties les plus basses que mes
trois jours plus tard grosse fièvre
fatigue la difficulté à respirer
je devrais peut être capable de régler
avant le temps entrepreneur général
aujourd'hui j'ai une très 10e puis je
peux même plus travailler j'ai demandé
aux responsables de la publicité d'avoir
une nouvelle publicité un peu plus
percutant
la voici la pub choc que le premier
ministre vu diffusé sur toutes les
tribunes dès demain croyez moi la cob 19
à ceyzérieu un entrepreneur dans la
cinquantaine pourtant pleine forme qui
vit avec les séquelles d'une
trachéotomie conséquences de la coved 19
il a été hospitalisé 45 jours dont 12
dans le comment c'est pas une question
de faire peur c'est pas une question
c'est de s'assurer de rendre un petit
peu plus concret l'impact l'impact de la
pandémie
le mandat du responsable de la publicité
gouvernementale n'est pas simple
comment faire entendre le message à la
population
malgré la saturation publicitaire
malgré la lassitude des québécois six
mois après le début de la pandémie les
jeunes comme les vieux sont informés des
consignes mais se disent dames ont
raison on fait attention
donc je peux me perdre en posant
quelques petits gestes ossature et que
pour maintiennent l'adhésion au conseil
cet élément là nous sommes c'est un
élément sur lequel il faut travailler
davantage convaincre les gens de limiter
les rassemblements privé est devenu son
principal défi tout comme pour la santé
publique qui tient ces rassemblements
responsable de la hausse des cas la
ligne f in nantes dialyse sur un fond de
jugement de valeur ou de culpabiliser ou
de regards donner des leçons faut faire
attention l'hôtel et le public de
l'arena réagit plus ou moins bien là il
faut s'assurer d'aller un cran plus loin
puisque c'est l'appel à l'action c'est
la mobilisation des gens en moyenne
chaque mois depuis mars le gouvernement
dépense 10 millions de dollars en
placements dans près de 540 médias des
publicités traduite dans 21 langues pour
joindre les allophones on compte 2
millions de clics sur québec point ca
le site web os toute l'information a été
centralisé aujourd'hui je veux
m'adresser à tous les québécois
l'achalandage sur le site web explose
après chaque conférence de presse de
françois legault le sport sont grandes
parce ma vie puis à rien comme de le
pratiquer en famille pour essayer de se
dépasser
mais en ce moment il faut continuer de
faire attention pour nous pour nos amis
pour notre famille quant aux clientèles
plus dur a joint poursuivre les mesures
en place
le premier ministre a demandé des
nouvelles publicités sur spotify snap
chatte techtoc instagram
encore une fois ça c'était un défi faut
s'assurer que notre message ait le bon
ton qu'on soit au bon ton au bon moment
croyez moi la cave 19
c'est horrible avec des témoignages
réels sans musique sans artifice le
gouvernement fait le pari que les gens
pourront finalement s'identifier aux
survivants de la coved 19 ils se verront
des princes radio canada québec